foreign
is one of the emerging programming
languages according to the most recent
figures python is the most used coding
language for about 80 percent of
developers syntax of this high level
programming language is simple to
understand and Python's large Library
System makes it a best choice for data
science machine learning and artificial
intelligence projects so hello Learners
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
and today we will be creating a
tic-tac-toe game using python but before
we begin if you love watching Rec videos
subscribe to our Channel like the
tutorial and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update
and before starting let us have a simple
quiz question to brush upon our
knowledge and a question is in which
year was the python 3.0 version
developed and your options are
2008
2000
2010 or 2005. please answer in the
comment section below and we'll update
the correct answer in the pen comment
you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section and I have an insightful for you
guys
if you are focused on building strong
foundational skills for career growth in
that case you can check out a free
course to Learn Python Basics with a
completion certification from scale up
by simply learn you can check the python
Basics free scale of course with the
link I will give the link in the
description below
now we'll start with the tutorial the
first thing we will do is create a
folder
will go to python projects and here we
will create a folder
for Tic-tac-toe
and inside we will open a command prompt
and open our ideally
and
I would be using the visual studio code
so for that I have written a command
that is code underscore code space
period so it will open my daily that is
Visual Studio code
and before starting I will show you guys
what we are going to develop or what we
are going to create as a tic-tac-toe
game
now we'll first see the demo of what we
will create
so
this is our code and
we'll just run it and you can see this
is our tic-tac-toe game that is we have
made it using Python and this is a
restart button to restart the game
that is if you are playing and if you
win so you can just click on restart and
you can restart the game and this thing
indicates that whose turn it is now so
extern now zero
x 0 x 0 x 0 x so you go to tie so it
would be displayed here and if someone
wins it will also be displayed here and
if it's a tie the whole box would be
turned to yellow color so these are the
functionings and now we'll move to
create our own game
so we have created a folder and named it
as tic-tac-toe now
we will create a file and name it as
tick Dot py and inside this file
we will start a
coding
and first thing we should do is import
the packages
and you have to install the packages I
have already installed the packages and
if you face any issues while installing
just comment down and we will get back
to you and tick enter is a python module
that is already installed as a module
when you install the python
so you don't have to install it again
so we will be using Canton only and the
random Library so for counter
we will import it and write the command
from printer import all the classes that
would be import
and
the second module you would import Is
Random so import
random you could see the commands to
install them on the web or you could
just simply type pip install random and
the module would be installed you could
either write this command on command
prompt on the ideally that is in the
terminal you can write it and you can
get the commands modules installed so as
I told you kinter is a python module
that is used to develop GUI graphical
user interface and there's no need to
install any module as it is already
installed as a part of the standard
python Library so moving on now we will
create a kinter window
and for that we will write a small
command
that would be
window
equal to
t k
that is we have created the counter
object
and we'll write window dot main Loop
so it's a loop that would keep on
repeating and
it will help us
to display a counter window
so we'll first save this
and run the file
so we have our counter window here
so this is a counter window we'll run it
again
you can see that we have created a
counter window and now in this window
we'll add the widgets and the elements
to create our own tic-tac-toe python
game
and starting with title first we will
give the title to the stick enter window
and we'll give it as tic-tac-toe game
only so for that we'll write the command
window Dot
title
inside we will give the title that would
be tick
tag
2.
so this would be that item we'll save it
and run it
so you could see
that this is the title and currently the
window is resizable you could see there
Arrow coming so you can expand it
at any site
so like in the further tutorial we would
mark it as node resizable that is we
would prohibit from resizing the window
and the next command we would be writing
would be configure to configure the
configuration of the window that is we
can change the color or configure
anything so here we would configure and
change the color of the background
window.configure and we will use
background
equal to
Gray
we'll save this and run it
you could see that the background of the
window has been changed to Gray
now let's set the geometry of the window
that is
how much the length and width it should
have that is width and height it should
have
so
we'll use window.geometry and inside in
inverted commas we would set the width
that is the first parameter that is past
its width and after that X the small X
and then the height of the window
so we'll save this
and run it
you could see that the
geometry has been changed and the width
is thousand and the height is 700 pixels
now we will make it
unresizable that is we will prohibit
from resizing the window so for that we
will write the command window dot
resizable
resizable
and you would mark it as
poles
volts
and save it and run it for you guys
now you could see that if I hover over
the edges of the window you won't be
able to see the pointer that expands the
window
so it has made it known resizable now we
will create a tic-tac-toe game and we
need a cross and a zero so for that we
will create a variable and name it as
players and inside that in the square
brackets
we will
mark them as X and the other as capital
O that would count as 0 only
and now
we have imported the random function and
whose turn will it come so
that would be the random thing only for
that reduce the random and the choice
function
so that will create a variable player
and use the random module
and go let's function that Which choice
and
pass the players variable so that it
could choose x0
and
and provide us with the output like who
can start first
so now
we would be creating
as this is our code
you could see the output so now we are
to be creating these buttons so these
all our buttons so to create them we
will write buttons
equal to
and inside the square bracket
we would provide
3
zeros and
after a comma
we would provide
another three zeros
and after another comma
dot provide
another three zeros
and now
we have created those buttons but it
won't be displayed as if I just save it
and run it for you guys you could see
this window only there's no output as I
have not
displayed anything
so first we will create a frame
so frame is a
widget that can hold any image or any
label or any widget on it so we would be
creating a top frame that is
if I show you the output so this is the
top frame
this blue color
we will create the top frame and on that
frame we would set the heading and then
the button that is the restart game and
then these turn widgets
so for that
first we'll create the top frame
and we'll create a variable top
underscore frame
and use the frame widget
and inside the widget we will pass the
window
as in the window we would be creating
this Frame so we pass the window and
we'll set the background color for this
Frame
and that is the blue color and we'll
write the color in the hexa code you
could write in hexa code or you could
just write the name of the color
so I know the hexa code for this 5D 6
D and it showing green but uh seven e
yeah this is the color that would be
displayed on the frame
and after the background color
comma
after this background color we would set
the width and height of this Frame
width that would be
1000 only we want this Frame to be of
whole size to curve the whole window
in the top section and after that we'll
set its height and that will set as 250.
it is 250. and now we will place this
Frame
this is the main thing that is the
geometry options which kind of provides
so when we place this then it would be
displayed on the counter window
so we would place this top underscore
frame
dot place
and we'll place it as x equal to 0 and y
equal to 0.
now we'll save this and run this
so you could say this is our counter
window and this is our top frame
and we will create a bottom frame also
but before that we will give it the
title that would be the game title as
tic-tac-toe using python
so for that
we will create a variable game
underscore title
and inside this
we will create a label
and the label would be placed on the top
frame so we'll pass the top frame first
and then we would set the background
color
and would set the same background color
as of the top frame only so hash
5D 60 70.
5D 60 70.
now we have set the background color now
we want the foreground color app so that
indicates which color the title should
be
so let's set the color of the title as
foreground equal to
white and we get
write the name of the color or you can
use the hexa code for hexa code for
white color is hashtag 6 times f
and now text that would be the heading
so we would set the text equal to
tic-tac-toe using python
okay now we would set the font
font for the title
so for that we would write
point
equal to and in circular brackets
you just use the default font
and
then Place comma and the
font size that we have set it as 48.
and now
we have set the game title but now we
have to place it so that it could be
displayed so for that you drag the
command game underscore title
dot place
and inside will pass the x coordinate X
we will have would be 135 and y equal to
0.
and it's showing the error as we have
not placed comma after text
yeah it's not showing I don't know we
will save this and run it
so you can see guys that inside this
window we have our title that is
tic-tac-toe using python
now moving on
we will create another label and that
label would be for turns that we have
seen that below the restart game we have
the text that shows whose turn it is so
for that we'll create a label
and use the label widget
inside the label variable only and we'll
pass to a frame because we want this
label on the top frame only
and we'll set text
equal to
player
Plus
turn it is
and now we'll set the font
and that would be equal to inside the
circular braces
we would name the
font
aerial
and we have to place it in inverted
commas
and now it's set its font size that is
30.
and set the background color
and we'll set the background color as
same of the top frame that is hashtag
5D 60 70.
5d60
70.
okay
and now we'll set the
Google okay this bracket was off
font will close it here
and remove this bracket
and after the
background color
we will Define the foreground column so
for which color
those turns would be displayed
foreground color would be equal to White
and no
we'll place this label so that it could
be displayed
label dot place
and we'll place it at x equal to
440
and y equal to
200.
okay
and it's showing the error so we'll see
what we have skipped we have not placed
a comma here
so we will save this
and run it
so you could see the extern here
so we'll add a functioning to it
so now
we would be creating a reset button now
and for that we'll create a variable
reset underscore
button
and use the button widget that is button
and that would be placed in the top
frame so we'll pass
top underscore frame
and the text we want to give to the
button that would be restart game
and now you would set the font
or which font
the button should have
what phones the button should have so
font equal to in circular brackets we
would place
area
and
set the
font size that is 30.
and then set background color
equal to
that would be the same as of the top
frame
that is 5D 60
70.
and after the background color we would
set the foreground color and we'll set
it as white only
and after the foreground color we would
place this
reset button but button has a command
also
so command is something which gives the
function to a button
and we will Define this function
and we'll name it as new game
so that it would reset the whole game we
would Define this function that is the
new game
and inside the next line we will place
this button
that is reset underscore button
dot place
and we will place it
as x equal to
360.
and y equal to 95.
so we have placed the
reset button now we will create a bottom
frame
so in that we would have the structure
of our game that is the nine boxes
so we'll create a variable and named as
bottom frame and create a frame widget
and inside that frame we would pass
window as it would be creating on the
window
and then set its background color
so
F would be capital for the frame and set
the background color
and we'll set the background color for
it as white only
now we would set the
foreground color
that is white
and
setup command no bottom frame don't have
anything now
so for bottom frame we would just create
a frame
and we would pass the window
and we would set the background color as
white and would set width and height for
it
width would be 400
and height
that would also be
400
we will create a square box for
Tic-tac-toe buttons
and now we will place this Frame
so to place it right bottom underscore
frame
Dot place
and we'll pass x equal to 265
and y equal to
300.
so we would place it
and
now
let's save it
and I'll run it for you guys
so first it wants us to
create these functions after that only
we could
execute this window or see the output of
the window
so
now we will move to create these
functions only
and we'll create it
just beneath this
and the first function we would create
would be the next turn
first I will write the function and
after that I will explain you its
functionality so we will pass row and
column here
and place the colon and here we will
make a global variable and name it as
player
and here we would
use if
buttons
that is we would Place those buttons
that
as uh like I will show you
so we'll place these buttons
as grid only
so it would have row and column
we want to place it we would set it as
grid so we would set it as rho equal to
0 and column equal to 0 or equal to 0
column equal to 1 rho equal to 0 column
equal to 2.
so this is how we gonna set this
so F buttons row column
and
the next
the text
that is equal to
t
and
we will create a
function and never test check winner
that is check underscore winner
that is
poles
and inside
if
layer
is equal to equal to
layer
0 that is the initial player
then
buttons
that is row column
and
I think before creating this function
that is next turn
first we should declare all the cases in
which a person can win
so for that also we will create a
function
and
name it as check winner
that is we have declared here so first
we'll Define this function only
check underscore winner
and
inside first we will
run a loop
or row
and 2 inch
and that is three
and inside if
buttons
that is row
0
and its text
said is text
and that is equal to equal to
buttons
Arrow
one
and what text it has
n is equal to equal to
buttons
at all
and inside
text
and it's
not equal to
empty
that is what we have done here is if you
see so we have stated that if
row 0
that is the first row row 0 and the
column 0 is equal to rho 0 and the
column 1 and the row 0 and the column 2.
and it's not equal to empty
and if they all are equal
then
we would
give it a green color
buttons
row
zero
dot config
and inside
will pass background
equal to Green
so
we will
give it a green color and where it goes
yeah here
so we have seen the first row if
the first row and all the three elements
that is all the three columns have the
same that is X or zero so it would be
turned out as green all the three would
be turned as green
so
the three buttons would be set as green
buttons
row
move one
dot config
and set its background
as green
dot config
and set the background
yes green
okay
and
it would return
true
so we have seen one possibility
now
you would see another possibility
that is
a winner could be this way
or it could be the column way
or like we have run a loop that is 4
range 0 that is the for first row then
the row would be changed to 1.
then this row then this row so all these
rows are completed now we would run a
loop so that we could check the columns
so for that we would run a loop
or
column
in range
3
and
write a if statement
that is if
buttons that is
0
and that is the row 0. and check the
column
so column would be
in Dynamic here
and pass
Ed
and that is equal to equal to
buttons
and the row one
and
the column that would be variable
and inside we will pass
text
equal to equal to
then buttons
and this row is
second that is the third row but index
is third and set the column
inside
text
and
that is
not equal to
empty
colon
so these columns would also be turned
into green
so for that we'll write buttons
0
column
dot config
and
configure with background color that is
equal to Green
okay
now I'll copy this
paste it here and
paste it in the next line
that is the next
column
and the next column
so it would be turned out to be green
and after that
it should return
true
so
we have covered these possibilities oh
sorry these possibilities now will come
have the possibility of the diagonals
so for that
we will
[Music]
um
creator
if statement only
if
we don't require any Loop here if
buttons that is
0 0
inside
text
that is
buttons
one one
and that is
equal to
buttons
that is 2 2
and that is not equal to empty
colon
then
these buttons
that is
would turn green
zero zero
dot configure
and set the background color
as green
okay
and
return
true
and if this is not the possibility we
will cover the second diagonal that is
LF
and inside
we'll just copy this
and State
the other diagonal that would be 0 to
1 1
and 2 0.
so for that
you're right zero
two
and the next is 1 1
and the next one is
two zero
and it's not equal to empty and it these
all three would also be configured as
green
if they all are equal
1 1
2 0
after that it should return
true
okay
now
I will cover another possibility that is
alif
and for that I will create
of function that is empty spaces
is
poles
so first we will create
the empty spaces function only
and after that we will create the Salif
statement
so
for that we will write
empty underscore
spaces
um and inside
we will Define that is
all the spaces
and that is equal to 9.
and now we'll run a loop
okay it's not closed now it's okay we'll
close it
now we'll run a loop
per row
in range
and now
or
column
in range
[Music]
and now we'll use if statement that is
if
buttons
that is we would check every row and
column
this text here
is not
empty
then
we would subtract
from the spaces
and enter
if statement that is if
spaces turn out to be zero
then
it should
return
false
else
return true
okay now we have
defined the empty spaces
now we will complete this alif statement
that is
for this
if the empty spaces is false
that is if all has been covered if space
is equal to equal to zero there is no
space left and it has returned false
so what we will do is
first we'll create a loop or Raw
in
range
3
now for column in
range
3
so we will turn the whole box as yellow
so for that buttons
row
column
use square brackets
row column
dot config
and will configure background color
equal to
yellow
and we will return type
that is of all the boxes are filled and
it doesn't satisfy
these
if statements that is there is no
consistent X over 0 in row or column or
in diagonals then we would turn it as
time
so we'll return it
return
time
and would make
the T capital
thank you
and
now we will play style statement
that is
return
poles
okay now we have
select all the facilities and
three spaces
now we'll complete our function
that is
the next turn and we have to create
another function that is the new game
so in the new game function we will
decide
who will have the first turn
so first we will Define this function
only that is new game
and inside
we will set
variable as global Global player
and
player equal to
random Dot
choice we have done this
in Windows also
and
we'll configure the label here
that we have created
that is this label we will configure it
and
change its text label dot configure and
change its text that is equal to
player
that we have choosed from the random
module and use the choice function so it
would choose either X or either 0
plus and now whose turn it is
okay
now
we will run a for Loop
four row
in
range
3
and
4
column
in range
e
would set buttons
row
column
Dot
configure
and would set the text
smt
for the new game
and background color
that is equal to
F 0 f 0 f 0
I will use the X support so I have to
use hash
that is white or you could use the hexa
code for white as hashtag 6f
okay so we have declares
Define and declared
okay three problems in this uh we will
resolve them
so we have declared the new game
function and moving on what you are left
is next turn
so now we'll complete that
is here and if statement and if player
equal to
layer 0 that is the first
so buttons
column
and
it's
text but will enter
be equal to layer
and F
check winner
is false
foreign
[Music]
equal to layer
1 the turn would be shifted to another
player
okay
now if check winner is false that is if
there is no player so
player would be shifted to player 1.
and
now we'll
change the label
that is this this would be changed that
is label.config
and
we would change it
and change it as
first word
set a text here
that would be text
equal to
the player turn would be changed for
that will write
text equal to
from the players
we would
now the turn has changed
and
another case
that is else if
if the winner is true
and if the winner is true
it will do we will change the label
we will configure it
and
change the text
equal to
players
one
and it wins
and we will
have another condition
alif
check
underscore winner
that is if it's equal to type
then we'll change the label we will
configure it
and set
text
equal to
tie
so now
we have
no
let me check
okay
this would be player one
it's true to
replace zero
if it wins
now we'll have a else condition
that is in else
we would be having all the other
possibilities that we are left and here
we would start with the player one
and else if buttons
that is
row column
and the text
and
is equal to layer
means that it's equal to player
then
if
check winner
is
false
if there is no manner currently
then
player is equal to
player
0
and we would configure the label
it is label dot config
and set text
equal to
and set
player
zero
and
would set its turn
and LF
relative that is
check winner
is true
then
label dot config
that if he's the winner then we'll
change the text that is equal to
player
one
and it wins
yeah
where testicle
player one bench
okay
now we have another
else if statement
that is if check winner
is equal to time
then we will configure this level
and set the text equal to
die
so we have
declared all the functions
now
what are the problems facing
okay now we will
set the buttons
in the frame
so that it should be displayed
for that we will run the loops
that is or
the row in range
3.
now for column
and
arrange
3
and now we would set them buttons
row
column
that is equal to
we'll declare them as button
and inside
first will pass the bottom name as we
want
them to win the bottom frame
and then
Define text
smt
and set the font
is
aerial
and set the font size as
40
now we'll set the width and height
that is comma
would set the width of
one button equal to five
and
write equal to 1.
and set the command
that would be Lambda
rho equal to
row
and
column
equal to
column
so equal to row column equal to column
and
our function that is
next turn
it will pass
the row and
column here
this sign is for
okay you have passed it
now
we would use the grid geometry function
to place it
so now we would place it buttons
row
column
dot grid
and we'll pass
it will equal to rho
and column
equal to
column
so we are done with the project
now we will run it
okay so there's an error
featuring error there's no error
okay
so we'll save this
and run it
so you can see that we have our
tic-tac-toe game
and there is no space here we'll place
it
and it's
also not showing functionality here
just make it correct
so first we'll go to label
um yeah plus
turn
make the space here
so you could see the space has turned on
now we will
see why the text is not
inserting in it okay
I am not
this is correct
and
okay
we have sent the text and the font okay
it's correct
so we'll just run it again
so yeah the functionality is [ __ ]
fine
yeah yeah you start game
no all the things are fine so we are
done with our project and with that we
have come to the end of this session
and I have an insightful for you guys
that is if you are aiming to get
certified in Python Programming and want
to build a python software development
career in that case you can check this
python certification course by simply
learn which will open the doors for the
best career opportunities to find the
details you can check this course Link
in the description box below
I hope the session was interesting and
informative and if you liked it please
let us know in the comment section below
and also do subscribe to our Channel and
stay tuned for more from Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here